يسعدني جدًا أن أكون هنا في
المركز الخامس حيث يركز على معايير العمل
لتحسين الضمان الاجتماعي ، لذا فهذه هي
قيم الصفقة الجديدة هناك وكذلك السيد
الرئيس
تشرشل كان مؤمنًا جدًا بذلك على
الرغم من أنهم يقولون إن حب الشباب
أثار قلق الشخص
في  هذا صحيح في لندن ،
حسنًا ،
إنه لمن دواعي سروري العظيم
أن يرحب بك السيد الرئيس للاتصال بك ، ومن
دواعي سروري أن أكون هنا رائعًا لرؤيتك
هنا في ما أعتقد أنه
رحلتك الخارجية الكبيرة الأولى منذ أن كنت
كذلك  يجب أن تكون منبهرًا
لقد كنت بلدي العظيم مرات عديدة
ولكن هذه هي المرة الأولى في
الرئيس الولايات المتحدة ،
الجميع سعيد للغاية برؤيتكم
الفتيات لمقابلة زوجتك نعم وقد
ذهبوا لفعل شيء آخر
قيل  رئيس الوزراء لدينا
شيء مشترك ، كلانا تزوجنا كثيرًا
فوق أنفسنا ،
لن أنزل من ذلك الشخص ،
لن أختلف مع
الرئيس أو في الواقع على أي شيء آخر
أه أنا  أعتقد أنه من المحتمل جدًا
أننا سنحصل على أمر
يمكننا الاستمرار فيه بشكل عام السيد
الرئيس
السيد الرئيس أعتقد أننا نتفق بشكل عام
مع المشكلة
السيد الرئيس ، هل تراها بمثابة
اختبار حظره فلاديمير بوتين أليكسيس